all right before we get started this
week we want to let you know that we
have acquired a sponsor what yeah this
is very legitimizing mm-hmm you know
even back in the days of playing t-ball
I remember looking out at the fences
because I was aiming for the fences baby
and I would see billboards back there of
local businesses I was like I have made
it as a t-ball player because there are
businesses who have placards in the back
of I don't think you can call out a
stadium field field there was a field
with a fence and and I knew I had
arrived so this is my majors this is
like t-ball we're in the majors of
podcasting now that we have a sponsor
and it's not just any sponsor people
this sponsor is square space the
all-in-one platform that makes it fast
and easy to create your own professional
website or online portfolio you can try
it out for free without even entering
your credit card information and once
you're convinced that the site is great
and let me tell you you will be make
sure you get 10% off by using offer code
R and L thanks to Squarespace dot-com
remember it's offer code are a and DL
it's like Randall if you didn't know how
to spell it correctly right I've always
failed Randall that way so I don't know
what the problem is I'm sorry Randall's
out there now it's time for an ear
biscuit welcome to ear of biscuits
I'm Linc and I'm Rhett it's time to
continue our conversation with shaycarl
the premier family vlogger on the
internet last week we talked about what
was like growing up Mormon and now we're
moving on to what it's like to be a guy
who puts his family out there for five
years every single day on you to
approaching five years yeah we discussed
the origin of his YouTube channels that
told at five years of daily vlogs has
taken on him is Shay burning out is he
ready to quit how does it impact his
family and also what is it like to go
from a guy who didn't even know what aim
Instant Messenger was to becoming the de
facto spokesperson for maker studios
whenever controversy hits ya I'm we get
a some good stuff I appreciate the
candid nature of what he has to say
about all
that it's very fascinating like I said
that's why we have a part two we didn't
want to truncate any of that
conversation so we think you will enjoy
it there's an interesting dynamic in
having your family on the internet at
all I think we can kind of give our
perspective because we you know we're
family men right we both have wives and
kids what why don't we start our own
little Chatard channels where where we
do that you want to I'm going to move
into the same house no you know we
talked about doing that you remember
this when we we're moving out - Tina's
expensive out yeah that our mortgages
our rent out here was so much higher
than our mortgages back in North
Carolina that we're like well maybe we
should just get a big house together I
mean there were serious talk about this
but then we were like you know what we
would kill each other yeah you know our
kids would probably kill each other but
if we were filming it we could probably
monetize it yeah so I'm now I'm
rethinking it I think the main factor
you know if you've been a viewer of our
videos for any length of time the
question once you find out that we're we
have wives and we have kids we see the
question a lot whoa what are the wives
like why aren't you we want to see your
wives that's the question we get a lot
especially like on the rent link
community that type of thing
well Christy my wife and Jesse Rhett's
wife I've we have just not been as open
to being on camera you know any have it
was what you're saying I mean I said
Kristi and Jesse here not been open to
being on camera and it's not the type of
thing that we want to push is we're not
vloggers in the first place so it's not
like we share every moment of our life
and then we're trying to cut around our
wives you don't want to be on camera
that's just not who we are we're not
vloggers and you know our wives don't
want a people augurs well and I think I
think a really one of the most important
aspects of why Shae is able to do it and
do it so well is that and he talks about
this is that he's able to
kind of put himself in that mood that
you need to be in in order to do a vlog
and and not that we aren't necessarily
but a lot of people don't realize just
like when it comes down to just the
business operations of running a
production company that makes Internet
videos we're pretty serious people and
it's like it isn't the kind of thing
where you're gonna like constantly want
to see a camera on us like sitting there
like thinking about that even though he
kind of talks about that it's not really
that much footage in any given day but I
think a lot of times were just like this
would be you know what you're gonna see
is you're gonna see me yelling at my
kids telling them to like clean their
leg goes up hey you know I'm not saying
that he doesn't have all the same issues
but it just it's never struck me as the
kind of thing that would be okay yeah
this is gonna be great content but I do
think that it's most that the main
factor has been that you know I watch
don't want to be on camera and we like
that and we know that the Internet can
be a cool place in terms of commenting
and things like that and you know I I'm
not you know jumping at the chance to
put my wife out there in front of the
scrutiny of the Internet if that's not
she doesn't want to be an entertainer
and you know and we know just as one of
the aspects of being a duo is constant
comparison you know we know it we know
exactly what all of you think about link
compared to me and me compared to link
physically emotionally we've heard every
single comparison that could be made
about us right and over you know seven
or eight years of doing this full-time
we we've developed thick skins it's a I
can take pretty much anything but I
don't want my wife to be subjected to
that because it isn't like you know
Katie let is being compared to another
wife every single every single day and
every single vlog but that's what the
internet would do if we put our wives
out there yeah they just would not be a
wise thing now our kids situation you
know I think but we have put our kids in
things because why well thank you have
use because they they've had fun with I
think from a young age I mean we don't
put them in a lot of our videos but just
kind of sneak them in here there seem to
be something that we were comfortable
doing
I mean lando by the time you get around
to
the fifth kid between our two families
you know we are doing a vlog because
we're actually doing daily vlogs at the
time we were trying that I think it was
daily and we so we have a vlog of you
coming in and visiting Lando and like
when he was one day old type of thing
that's really an exception but around
that same time we did that we use our
kids as weights a very much inspired by
shaycarl type of thing to do mm-hmm what
we used our kids as weights and they had
a lot of fun with that I mean they liked
being a part of it I mean they make a
little cameos and when I like you know
when we did the the Arby's commercial
and and Shepherd gotta be in it like
light was disappointed that he didn't
get to be in it right you know and then
we'll use a lot for something else and
Shepherd will be upset that he doesn't
so and your kids the same yeah deal so
they they want to be a part of it and
they would probably be a part of it more
if we let them have their way but we we
kind of try to keep tabs on it a little
bit and Lily made a cameo in the get off
the phone video she ended it and then
Lincoln was he said he wanted to be in
it he said if I was in it I woulda done
better than she did he told me his
dinner table he's like vying for it's
like well you all can't be in everything
so he would have done differently he
well I didn't go that far
he didn't give any details I didn't
question her performance yeah I mean she
was right there but you know the
complete opposite of that mentality has
been what Shay has done with this family
and you know we're not making any
judgments about it I think it's
absolutely fascinating that he has made
the decision and we get into talking
about this and like how does he deal
with his wife and how does he deal with
the fact that what if his kids don't
want to do this one day because he has
made the decision to put his life and
his wife and his kids out there and he's
that he is the premiere family vlogger
the there's millions of people out there
who have decided that they are gonna
tune in they're gonna watch them live
their lives and that's what every single
day for for approaching five years and
it's fascinating the conversation is
fascinating and let's get right into
this base camp
[Music]
now we want to talk about I mean you've
got the whole transition story from not
when you transition from a woman to a
man wasn't Mormon the transitioning from
you know being a DJ into YouTube and I
think we you know people can hear you
tell that story in a couple of different
places so we don't necessarily have to
go go into that but we know that there
was a number of jobs and then kind of
getting into the the YouTube thing and I
think that one thing we like to talk
about is you know transition from being
one of those early YouTube guys with a
channel that was popular and then
transitioning into sort of being the
first family right of YouTube so let's
get into that yeah I've heard us
referred to as and this isn't a term
that I made up but we've been referred
to as the first family of YouTube which
I thought nulls kind of was you know
like you guys remember no I'm sure it's
like he had four kids and nots is still
a really good friend of mine but yeah I
mean when I found YouTube it was at a
point in my life where you know we just
had our third kid and I was 27 years old
and I just hated what I was doing for a
living like I just I always believed
that I could love what I did
you know like growing up I was always
you know I skied and I wanted to be a
professional skier you know when I was
growing up cuz I just wanted to do
something I loved so I figure you know
80% of your life is your job and if you
hate your job then you hate your life
you know so I got a computer and got
online and found Philip DeFranco and
just you know at first I was because
back then you didn't start a YouTube
channel to make money I think now people
like oh I want to start a YouTube
channel so I can like become rich in a
famous youtuber has an occupation yeah
you know like that's a job now but back
then it was like oh I just I was
addicted to the conversation
in fact the probably the only video that
I've ever deleted is my very first
youtube video on my shaycarl channel and
so the very first thing I got on I was
like there was this I think I looked up
he has ever seen this video it's about
this black preacher
like bones these two Mormon missionaries
and like I had just you know I was like
Oh in what way you mean it's like in a
Bible is like a Bible bash situation
like they were in like a Denny's parking
lot and these two missionaries came up
to talk to this guy and this guy they
had a camera roll and he's like oh look
at these two guys look at these two guys
and these two missionaries walk up and
they're you could tell they're just two
greenie missionaries or like - 19 year
old kids that have no idea what they're
doing or where they're at and this guy
is like this you know preacher from the
south who knows the Bible really good
and he just like well what about this
what about this and these two kids are
like uh-uh and it's like I was just like
rolling my eyes like no and so there was
this guy who uploaded that video called
Utah a night he's like this ex Mormon
who was like super anti Mormon and so
you know how religious debates happened
on the internet so I started like well
these these poor kids I don't even know
what hit him and he's like yeah cuz
they're not they don't have the truth
and we started like kind of getting this
like comment battle back and forth and
I'm like I'm like let's meet let's meet
and talk about this cuz I figured he
lived in Utah so I made a video cuz it
was funny at the time because you got to
know people just in the chat of the
YouTube video it was so small a time
that there was like ten people for like
a week
that were commenting back and forth on
this video where it's like you got to
know these people was like a chatroom
exactly in the YouTube comments and it's
like I would come back to that video
every day to see what the newest thing
they said was and then I would type
something and then he would type
something it's like a week long
conversation in the comment section of a
YouTube video and you want to memorize
yeah I was like let's meet let's have it
cuz it got to like we're like teams
there's like you know sides like I agree
with Shay and I agree with this other
guy and so I was like I was like it's
like my first YouTube made up I made a
video cuz everybody I knew my channel
talked about like my first 15 or 20
subscribers is from this like big debate
in the comments section of this video
and so I made a video and I'm like hey
like hey you tonight we've been talking
for the last week and have them like
let's meet I'll meet you halfway I live
in Idaho you live in Utah let's meet at
the border and have lunch and talk about
this and then of course he's wouldn't
agree to do it he's like no I'm not
gonna meet with you and blah blah blah
and I uploaded that video that's
probably my very first youtube video and
then I found out like there's all this
other stuff on YouTube I know
like searching around and then I'd
uploaded like my second out next two
videos or me and my brother seen with
helium balloons too and my mom's 50th
birthday and then I uploaded a video of
me doing backflip on skis just like
anything I had I uploaded and then I was
like I don't want to be known as the guy
who's like fighting with this guy about
religion so I deleted that video and I
think I'm pretty sure that's the only
video I've ever deleted off of any of my
channels is that very first video so you
were married with three kids at the time
yeah and you were working day job was
what I just had started my own granite
countertop business I had done granite
countertops for like three years and I
had just started my own business but
YouTube was kind of your outlet I mean
yeah it seemed everyone else who was
doing that was younger right yeah so I
was other than Alton like zip ster I was
probably one of the older guys that was
getting on YouTube at the time and it
wasn't I never liked to be an
entertainer like that was always my
personality but that was never like a
viable career like to be an actor or an
entertainer like that was always like oh
that's not realistic you know so I was
good with people I could talk to anybody
so in my mind I was always gonna be a
Salesman you know all those tests they
give you in school like fill out this
personality thing and I'll tell you what
you're gonna be when you grow up so me
it was always like I would be in
marketing or sales because like it was
good with people I was creative and so
that's what I was gonna do and I loved
you know countless yeah well that's
that's the thing that's why I started my
own business cuz like at least I want to
work for myself you know I always had an
entrepreneur spirit so I was like at
least I know I'm not gonna do
countertops forever but at least I want
to be doing under my own terms but
that's okay but you're making videos in
your in your spare time yes with three
kids I don't know how you had any but
whatever and but you were still engaging
in all of this YouTube right shamanic
see when I you were creating videos of
doing acrobatic yeah see because it was
perfect timing because I was working at
a granite shop right before I started my
own granite business and I was working
50 60 hours a week so I never would have
had time but I just started my own
business and so I could do one job a
week and have a lot of extra spare time
so I remember the day where it's like my
wife came in and she's like you need to
go finish that job I'm like
I'll had to make a YouTube video like I
was more interested in making the
YouTube video than going to finish this
$10,000 granite job that I was
contracted to do up on like the rich
part of town you know so it's like and
what did she say to that she's like I
don't care honey
the bills you know that's what it was is
like our mortgages come up and it was a
scary proposition for her to own our own
business because before then you know I
had a steady job with a paycheck and she
was nervous about like well how are we
gonna pay the bills if you know you're
on YouTube and so then the second I
found out I could get paid on YouTube
was like I could be part of this
community and a part of this discussion
because that's what I was addicted to is
just like I was talking to people from
all around the world you know but you
weren't you were making you weren't
necessarily making vlogs you were
milking I was just making like rants
like it just like whatever videos I
could think of and I had no idea you
could make money and it was just like
what funny idea could I make and that's
when I found Philip DeFranco and I was
like this kid has like his own show
that's why I was so shocked I was like
is this like is there a network behind
it cuz he had this like little intro
with some music and he had this little
phone he had this little the philip
defranco show and I was like it seems
like a TV show on the internet but it
seems like he's just doing it by himself
and there's I think he had 60,000
subscribers at the time and I was like
that's more people than live in my town
and this he seemed like a kid and he was
like 20 21 years old it's a lot of
countertop that's a lot of countertops
to be doing and so I was like I can talk
like that like I watched a show and I'm
like I can do that I can you know say
funny things and you know and so he had
this he uploaded this video like I'd
watch like two or three of his videos
and then like the next day he uploaded
this video tied this video titled how to
get a popular online show or series and
I was like yeah how that's what I want
to do I want to do that and he had a
contest that said submit a video as a
video response and I'm gonna pick the
top five that I like and I'm gonna
promote you on my website and I was like
oh dude this is great so at the time I
was just getting into being a radio DJ
and at the the night DJ he gave me this
segment called the rant of Shay where I
could call in and just rant about
something so I I came up with this rant
about hand sanitizer that I called the
he-man German
it's like you know how no hand sanitizer
says it kills 99.99% of the germs what
about that point oh oh one percent
that's the one germ I want dead because
obviously he's the strongest germ if I
kill all the other germs and he's still
left
he's the germ I want dead cuz he's the
one that survived the apocalypse with
the drain sanitizer so I do this big
rant about that and submit it to Phil's
video and he liked it and he put us on
his website there was five of us and it
was like there was a week for people to
come watch those videos and vote on who
they liked the best would we know any of
the other five that at the time no I
think they've all faded away and losers
yeah okay more committed vote I think I
got second or third and everybody voted
on the website I think cuz I think the
guy who won had a thousand subscribers
and I had zero you know I was like I was
just on the website so I was kind of a
nobody but this other person had like a
thousand subscribers and so he won but I
remember later I don't know if this is
true or not I talked to Phil and Lindsey
and they're like we wanted you to win we
wanted you to win because it was like a
poll where I would check every day I'm
like I'm a second place I'm in second
place and I I didn't win but then you
know later feels like he's like I'm
gonna promote you so he I think he sent
me a message or something on YouTube it
said hey get on AIM so we can talk I'm
like what's aim I had no idea cuz I just
got this computer I had I had never
taken a typing class computer class or
anything so I remember googling aim I'm
like oh it's like a chat thing so we got
an aim we started talking he's I can't
give you a shout-out you said you should
submit partner application to the
partner program I was like okay okay so
then he I remember the vlog because I
think it happened like two or three
vlogs after he told me it was gonna or
his videos or his show and every day he
would upload a video I'm like oh is this
it is this it
and it was and then finally he promoted
me in one of his YouTube videos because
before that it was just on his website
and then all sudden it was like I got
three thousand subscribers in a day and
it was like I just spent all day
refreshing YouTube it's like refresh 20
more refresh five more and it was like
this is amazing and then I remember
getting my first check from Google
Adsense for 300 bucks I was like that's
I'm like honey look I just paid for
groceries doing this YouTube thing so
did you start doing rants because that's
what worked or that's just I mean that's
what I was kind of doing on that night
show on the radio show cuz I was like
well what am I gonna do like you know I
didn't know what I was gonna do so I
just tried to think of like funny
scenarios and and then I did a thing
where I was dancing to my wife's unitard
and just whatever I could think of I one
of my early videos is me trying to put
this five gallon water jug on the water
container blindfolded and it just like
falls on the floor and I you know I I
hammed it up like I fell down and
there's just five gallons of water all
over our kitchen floor which I knew is
gonna happen because I thought I'm not
gonna just try to beat my wife and get
it perfectly because I that's not
entertaining but if I drop this five
gallons of water all over our kitchen
people are gonna be like holy crap I
remember all of these videos because we
montage them together for the music
video we made for you when you win a
super note still one of my favorite
songs but yeah you had a lot of material
that was montage right he's getting on
his roof and yeah jumping onto a
trampoline in his backyard and he has
children on it wearing a unitard yeah
this big fat guy for my toe and I think
I mean that was the interesting thing is
that a lot of people saw the mismatch of
how big and fat and bearded I was and
then how like cute and petite my wife
was and it was like I had a lot of
people I knew were very athletic yeah
and that's what was also ears like this
300-pound dude is like jumping on his
roof like a ninja you know like how was
he able to do that because I was always
so athletic in school and stuff but I
just gained all this weight and I think
people really thought that we were like
a scripted show like we were the
real-life King of Queens and so people
thought it was fake they thought like
you guys this is like like lonely girl
kind of because that's like right after
lonely girl had coming out that she was
faking so I think a lot of people
thought that our family was fake like it
was a script like why would this girl
ever marry this guy you know and so I
think that helped us actually at the
first well let me skip ahead and ask
about that and then we can go back but I
you know when you decided to start
losing weight you created a shade loss
channel now this is many years later
once you are you know very well
established well actually get a year
something like you didn't you didn't
start losing weight with that first year
now that's my fight Elda bunch yeah but
when you actually did
are losing weight was there a calculated
decision or was there a moment of pause
that this is gonna mess with my brand
you know the thing that you were talking
about it oh you guys this big guy who's
funny with the big beard and the little
wife well you don't want the little guy
and the little wife
you know kind of thing so I learned that
the hard way I never thought about that
I never thought that
oh I'm the big fat loud obnoxious guy I
can't lose weight or I lose my branding
I never thought about that I just
thought I want to lose weight I've been
saying I'm gonna lose weight for a long
time and I was finally doing it and then
I learned I lost a lot of my audience
because of it I used to sell when I sold
shirts I would sell a majority to three
and Forex shirts like I would sell if I
if I put some shirts online I would sell
a hundred xxx shirts you know 50 2x and
like maybe no smalls maybe a few so a
majority of my audience were bigger and
when I started losing much weight did
you lose at one point I had lost like
the highest that I mean that now I'm
like 190 now I've packed on a few pounds
of muscle but I was 281 and I got down
to like 165 when I ran the Nashville
Marathon so like a hundred and fifteen
pounds total well and what did you see
in terms of sales and what were the
conclusions it was it like views
definitely went down it was I instead of
being the fat funny guy I was the skinny
douchebag like I always would get that
like oh you're so full of yourself now
Shay and I was it was like really hard
for me for a while because it was like
what like I just wanted to do this for
my health like I wanted to be able to be
there for my kids and be able to play
with my kids and now it's like I'm
looked on as like this douche bag who
just thinks he's so better than
everybody else cuz he lost weight and
I'm like no I just I want to be healthy
you know and I think what it was and
I've kind of and I don't know if this is
100% true but I definitely think that
for some people that is true is that
they saw this kind of big fat slob of a
guy with this beautiful wife and
beautiful children and kind of like what
appeared to be this perfect life where
it didn't seem like I had to try it all
it was like I'm just I'm the fun
party animal can do whatever he wants
and still have this perfect life with a
great wife and good children but really
it takes a lot of work to have that you
know and it takes a lot of sacrifice and
dedication and when people saw that it
wasn't as easy it wasn't like this you
know like movie kind of script it was
like they saw the struggle and I was
like I don't know why I think people
weren't rooting for me anymore or
something I don't know but you know I I
don't make any decisions based on what
my audience thinks you know I just do
things that you know I think are best
for me and my life and the health of me
and my family and you know that's what
the vlogs are like we are who we are in
the vlogs I mean anybody who knows me
from YouTube and has hung out with me in
real life I don't know if you guys agree
or disagree with this but I am the same
guy as I am on the YouTube videos I'm
just living my life and filming it every
day you know so it's not like I'm making
these calculated decisions that will
help my career because I would love to
just make I mean sometimes I have this
fantasy of like logging off the internet
and never getting on again like mm-hmm
seriously it sounds so appealing to me
to go to the mountains of Idaho build a
cabin and just never get on the internet
again like to me that's like that would
be awesome yeah well let's talk about
that because there you know obviously
there was a time and maybe it was just
very natural at first to be like I'm
gonna include my family in this because
they're here and I want to be with them
that's what it was it was just like this
is great like my family can be my job
because I get cused a lot of like you
know expose yeah exploiting my children
like I'm not putting my kids in the
video so that my views are better I just
want to be around my kids and if I'm
doing a video every day where I can make
money hanging out with my kids like
that's a freaking dream come true you
know like me and Colette will be driving
in the car and I'll be like honey like
what if I told you five years ago that
I'm gonna have a job where we get paid
more money than we've ever gotten paid
ever and we get to be together as a
family all the time and all we have to
do is film we have to have a camera out
for 20 minutes a day and then edit
every day like that would be amazing
about telling ourselves that five years
ago and he'd be like I wouldn't believe
myself no way and that's the reality of
our life and so it was a way to make
money so that I could be with my family
and so it's like I say about this you
know like for instance maker studios
when we moved out here four years ago
and started maker studios
if maker studios sold for a bunch of
money and I made a lot of cash off the
shares that I have maker studios to me
it's very tempting to just like
disappear off the internet and just like
cuz I'm not on the internet to get
famous I'm on the internet to provide
for my family while I'm with my family
cuz that's the most important thing to
me is just being with my family and if I
sold makers if maker studios sold and I
made a bunch of money I don't know I say
that I would like to disappear and never
gonna internet but I think I would miss
it you know but I definitely would scale
back and I wouldn't share as much as we
share ok well let's let's talk about
that more but to take one step back I
think that it seems to me that the whole
daily vlog thing and that becoming your
mainstay and and source of income and
what it is was kind of an accident it
was a second channel totally totally I
mean how did that happen because
shaycarl them the first channel it was
more space yeah you would include your
kids in that but when was the decision
to start doing early vlogs so when I
turned 29 years old I had been on
YouTube for about a year I'd built up my
shaycarl audience I think I had like
40,000 subscribers and it was always
like coming up with skits and ideas and
I was like oh man I'm 29 like this is
the last year of my 20s you know what am
I gonna do own I wanted to do something
that was like monumental like something
that's like if I did this that would be
crazy something like a goal that I could
set it be like so hard to do but if I
just totally committed to it I could do
it I thought what if I made a video
every single day for the last year of my
20s like I just say that out loud yes I
just say that where Charles Trippy could
hear me and then say you have to do it
because I thought that's what happened I
thought you guys said well I'll do it if
you do it oh no no like I started it and
then like a month and a half later he's
too
well I mean I copied an Frank you know
she wrote in her diary every day Charles
he's probably like my best friend from
the internet so yeah like I just
actually sent a letter to the Guinness
Book of World Records telling them that
I have missed days and that he is the
longest consecutive vlogger even though
I started a month and a half before
Charles I've missed days in the last
five years and he has not he has not
missed one day in oh well I mean coming
up this March will be my five-year mark
and so I think he started in May I think
he's heard in May first so he started
like a month and a half after me so I
ever had to write a letter to whom it
may concern' at the Guinness Book of
World Record company because they
recognized you yeah they said well what
about this
everybody is claiming that shaycarl has
logged longer than you but I haven't
vlogged longer consecutively I may have
started before him but I um anticipated
you missed um over the last last five
years maybe 10 or 12 days maybe and I
don't like to admit that as a daily
vlogger I don't like to admit that and
what has determined that it's like you
know where we had been like traveling
and it's late and I couldn't get the
internet and it was like you know the
kids are cranky and I'm like honey I
gotta upload this video and she's like
stressed and I was like I gotta find the
internet because there's the streak and
she and finally it's like okay screw it
like my family is more important than
getting this video up you know like my
kids were miserable my wife's hungry
like I can't you know make them wait at
the Starbucks in some random town
because I have to upload the vlog now
it's that first day though is there's
this is their this party this like you
know what this is it I almost quit the
vlogs a couple times because it's like
man I've missed I think there was one
day when I missed two days in a row and
it's like you know what it's over I'm
done I'm not gonna upload videos like
I'm not gonna do that daily videos
anymore but then I was like no I gotta
keep going but I haven't missed a day I
haven't missed a day for like the last
year and a half like I've been very
consistent over the last year and have I
haven't missed any days there's still
something that you are doing yourself
yeah I edit shoot everything oh yeah
that's a full-time so on when I can have
editors though there was about a year
and a half where I had Brett the intern
and Denise vlogs edit my video you went
back yeah it was it was
it didn't do as well when I had editors
it lost some of the personal feel and I
just I missed doing it and I missed
adding and little things like they would
edit and upload the video and I'd go
watch it I'm like oh why'd you cut this
part out and I remember having
conversations with Denise one day I was
filming Sun tarde at school and they
were doing a play and she edited the
video so that the play worked with the
storyline but there was a moment in the
play where the kid like forgot his line
and Gavin like whispered the line Gavin
son [ __ ] I don't care you can leave it
in
Gavin whispers the line to the kid and
then he's like oh so then he tells the
line so Denise edit it so it looked good
in the play but like no I want the part
in where he whispers the line that's so
cute and she's like oh I thought you'd
want the play to flow I'm like no I
don't care about the play I want to see
him whispering the line you know so
there's little moments like like valley
it wasn't her fault or anything but just
like things yeah it's like I wish you'd
have put that in and so then I was like
I'm just gonna do it myself because
there's more of a personal feel and so I
just you know I like doing it better
like them and use have done better since
I took over incrementally views have
gone up I'm tangible tangible I mean
yeah I can look at Google Analytics for
the last 12 months every single month
the last 12 months Shaytards views have
increased where last month we had 22
million monthly views and that's maybe
the fourth highest viewed month in our
entire history well having a having
another baby ourselves so on one hand
you're saying you know I wouldn't treat
this occupation for the world I get to
be with my family and make this my
living on the other hand you're saying
I'm really starting to think if I had
the opportunity or I'm actually maybe
even looking for the opportunity just to
stop cold turkey or to get out of it
entirely so I'm interested in that
dynamic I think here's what it is I
think I'm a little bit burned out to be
honest like I think after five years I
need a break and I think if I had a
month vacation where I could go just
wherever away from the internet because
I have been on my phone on the Internet
every single day for the last six years
if I had a month where I went
me and Colette talked about this the
other day that coming March will be my
five year anniversary and then on spring
break whenever that is for the kids get
out of school we're gonna go for a week
vacation a real vacation where it's not
like a YouTube gathering or like a brand
deal or something where I'm going for
work where I'm gonna we're gonna go on a
real vacation where I leave on purpose
my phone on my dresser at home and then
I get an airplane without my laptop and
without my phone like tonight that
freaks me out to think about that but at
the same time it sounds like pure bliss
it's like I am just not gonna be on the
internet at all for a week well that's
talking one week that's different blend
yeah I feel like if I had a month and it
just kind of like got away from it I
feel like I would want to come back cuz
I do I love it I love making videos I
love seeing the interaction I just at a
point right now where it's been every
day for five years I'm like I just need
a break and I so I think when I say like
I would love to disappear into the
wilderness of Idaho and never get on the
internet again I think that's just I
just need a break so I think after I
after this five years I'm definitely
gonna stop the dailies after this five
years and I'm gonna focus more on doing
shaycarl videos and we'll still vlog
probably four days a week but I'm gonna
you know not have that strict of a
schedule where it's like and on Sundays
that's after March 5th after we hit that
five years I am NOT even that's my goal
as I'm not gonna get on the Internet at
all on Sundays because I still upload a
one-take video on Sundays where I just
film a one clip I don't read it and I
just upload it but I'm still on Twitter
and I'm still reading and I'm still in
the comments because I can't upload a
video without reading comments like I'm
I'm always reading comments so that's
gonna be the new rule after the five
year mark after I get that you know five
years of daily vlogging under my belt
Sundays that's my new rule for life I'm
not getting on the Internet at all and
so are you fearful of the at that moment
no I'm excited about it but then like my
family questions me like yeah right Shay
like you you won't be able to do that
like I tell my brother like I'm gonna go
on this month vacation not get on the
internet he's like he says he doesn't
believe me thinks he's like you're not
get on Twitter you're not gonna
Instagram anything you're not gonna read
comments I tell myself and I'm not I
don't know I'm excited it's like it's
like a new part of me that I have an
experience in the last six years not
doing a daily vlog
you know talk about the toll the
challenges for you and your wife and
your relationship and your family then
the chin just what kind of toll does
that take on you as an individual and as
a Wells as a family it's interesting
because I mean the vlog is a huge
priority in our family I said when I
come home tonight from the podcast if
this house is spotless then I'll take
you guys all out to a movie and get a
treat tomorrow
so tomorrow I know what will happen is
I'd be like dad I'm like they'll come to
me and they won't say dad is the time to
go to the movie they'll come to me
they'll say dad is the vlog up yet cuz
it's like they know I can't do anything
till the vlogs up so it's not like you
know also there's like I feel like a big
commitment to a lot of people like a lot
of people who watch our videos they
really rely on them so I feel like this
huge commitment to these people who've
supported us for so long
over the years watched all of these
videos bought our merchandise supported
anything we've done it's like I have a
huge commitment to them you know so it's
like first and foremost is my family but
then it's like the Shaytards are a
family you know all these people who
watch our videos were kind of like a
proxy parent for a lot of these kids
there's a pressure
oh yeah it's a huge pressure because
like kind of toll does that take on your
relationship I mean I imagine you edit
out the the arguments right yeah well
like this is a funny conversation we
have with Charles and Ally were like all
at the end of the night I'll go to
import the footage from the day cuz I
just I like to have it all imported in
the timeline so that when I wake up I
can start to edit and so I'll be
importing the clips I make honey you
only got one clip today you know like
there'll be those fights she's like I'm
sorry I was busy and it's like those I'm
like honey this is our job it's so easy
all you have to do is turn on the camera
for six minutes like four clips for one
minute clips you know like we've gotten
in these pretty heated conversations
she's like well I couldn't cuz I do
that's Mike babe just turn on the camera
so I didn't feel like vlogging like
honey this is a dream like you realize
how many people wish they had this job
so we've gotten fights like that you
know and are you thinking at that moment
I should be filming this argument right
but people would love that people would
love to see that but no like you don't I
don't wanna turn on the camera when
you're fighting trials and Ally actually
tell me that when when they're yelling
one of them was hurting the camera on
just so they stopped so it's
you're not gonna yell at the camera when
the cameras on you know but it's but
it's that but there's that you've drawn
the line because there is a principle of
the same reason you didn't put the
watercooler on the first time that you
made it dramatic more appealing there is
a more entertaining way and it's what
cite its buenas also what separates what
you do from say a reality yeah that
because you're the producers the drama
yeah
so here's how I think about that because
I think people would love to see me and
mommy tarde fight just because people
love gentlemen I mean our humans human
specie that's why reality TV does so
well I just feel like there's so much of
that already that they don't need it
from us like I feel like I want the
Shaytards to be a place where they can
come and always count on having
uplifting positivity optimism happy
cheerful people too you know cuz I feel
like there's so many kids today that
just have a cry me I read the comments
and I just feel like crying like my dad
just came home drunk again I wish I I
wish you know che and Colette were my
parents and it's like they just live in
these lives that are their parents are
fighting all the time
they go to school and they get bullied
you know they have all these horrible
experiences and they can come home and
get on the computer and have 15 minutes
of just pure happiness silly time where
I'm wrestling the kids throwing them
around and you know when I could leave
those arguments in there but I just feel
like they've dealt with that all day
long you know I want to I want to be a
place where they can always count on
coming to have a you know to go away
being like ah I feel better now like
it's interesting that your reason is for
what it does for your audience but
there's also the reason I would imagine
that you want some privacy
right and when you're fighting right
you'd rather just get it over with and
exploit it for entertainment value like
hold on honey I'm gonna yeah let me turn
on the camera and you should have you
know yeah exactly exactly and at the
same time okay so I have this like
saying that's not my saying but I've
kind of adopted it the happiness is a
choice and that's a very literal thing
that I learned because I had to turn the
camera on and be that happy guy because
there's days where you know I mean it's
so ridiculous to even say but everybody
wakes up in a pissy
mood everybody wakes up like ah I don't
want to do it I don't want to vlog I
don't want to turn the camera on and be
like hey guys okay what are we doing you
know and I just like I'm gonna quit I
don't want to do this anymore but it's
like okay so I turn the camera on and I
smile and I sit up straight and I
breathe deep it's like hey guys I'm blah
blah blah and I do the clip and it's
like a two-minute clip and I turned the
camera off and I'm like I actually feel
better
like I physiologically feel my my body
feels better just because I sat up
I took some deep breaths I smiled it
changes how I feel and I'm like that's
like a choice people like happiness
isn't a choice Shay I'm like it is I
didn't I felt like crap before I turn
the camera on and after I did that vlog
and tried to be funny and tried to you
know joke around my kids I really felt
better okay Shay you're making it too
happy what I'm trying to get at here is
what is the dark side you just want the
dirty stuff so one time my girlfriend's
dad ripped my shirt you know like it's
it's funny but like we might we've come
so far like I think there's been like
fights in the past and stuff with me and
my wife but we've come so far and
experienced so much that like there is
no downside of it like I I'm constantly
just conflict or fighting but I mean the
how does it affect my kids yeah that I
constantly take their temperature on
that I'm always like you know I hold
Gavin aside or when we're driving I'm
like what do you think about the vlogs
cuz the second that it's like I feel
like I'm forcing them to be funny on
camera for YouTube that's when all the
fun stopped you know it's like I'm not
gonna be like get up here and be cute
you know what I mean it's like if they
don't want to do it I don't want to
force them into it but it's totally the
opposite like I am reining them back
because they they want to be in more
videos they want to start their own
channel and I'm just like uh it's just
Jess I know the comments out there you
know and it's like Terms of Service I
just keep saying you guys can't tell
you're 13 it's a rule I always say this
is a dream come true of a dream I never
knew I even had it'll be the most
interesting part of this is to see what
my kids will turn out to do in their
lives you know if they'll all be
entertainers or but they all say they
want to sing
be performers but I much like you can do
whatever you want you don't have to do
this and do you anticipate that whatever
it is that they decide to do will be
public knowledge because yes it'll be on
the Internet that's what I get worried
about cuz I it's like I just see if I
foresee a day when one of my kids writes
a book about this whole experience is
like you know baby TARDIS Emmie I
imagine Emmie reading a book saying my
life has baby tarde you know it's almost
like a character online you know they
are the same person but it's just like
online persona that has been created by
me for them and I kind of joke sometimes
like well if you're raised on a farm you
got to go out and milk the cows if you
like to or not you're born in chez
Karl's household you have to be cute on
camera you know like I say I would never
force them into doing that but it'll
just I always say like you guys can do
whatever you want and I'll support you
and it'll just be interesting to see
what they decide to do and it seems like
you know you've developed a little bit
of a margin or freedom to be able to say
you know what guys we could stop this
and this isn't necessarily your
livelihood at that point you know with
the success that maker studios is right
right so that's that work I mean it's
great to not have to worry about money
anymore and I'd hate to talk about money
because it's just like you know people
don't I don't know there's like some
jealousy some people get it's like
they're they're happy for our success
but some people it drives them you know
it's like the comments come in like well
no we're all not lucky like you Shay to
be able to you know it's like clever
working my butt off for the last five
years and I believe in you know that I
don't believe in a scarcity complex
where it's like a lot of people feel
like if somebody else succeeds that that
means then there's less success in the
universe for them like if you succeed
that means I can't succeed it's like
there's plenty for everybody
you know and it does feel good to not
have to rely on the daily vlogs for
money anymore you know we've got to the
point where we're totally debt free all
five of our kids college education is
totally set like we have utmost like we
just fill out all the paperwork so like
we're in a very comfortable position and
the reason we don't do the daily vlogs
for money anymore it's just because one
like I want to hit that five year mark
and like I said I have a lot of
responsibility to that audience those
kids who have those crappy lives who I
see those comments every day of like if
it weren't for you guys I wouldn't have
gotten through my senior year or you
know like just there's so many stories
of kids that I just it's sad to find out
how many bad parents there are out there
of parents that just don't support their
kids and just fight non-stop and but
from a livelihood standpoint so you're
doing it for them and for the five-year
milestone but from a livelihood
standpoint your position at maker what's
your title I mean as a founder writer
whole founder but it's like I don't run
day to day at maker like I go into maker
studios like once a month I actually try
to stay away from because it's just like
every time I go in there it's crazy so I
I just make my content and we have a
sales team who they'll they'll call me
with brand deals or like hey here's a
deal
so-and-so we just did one with urban
shredder Hot Wheels so you know have it
this is a deal for your channels yeah
yeah for my channel then also as a
founder I mean you were able to say ours
there's times we go in and vote like on
the board like if you know there's
current things that are going on right
now that like I've had to go in to like
discuss like changes in you know
leadership and maker studios and stuff
like that but I don't I don't have any
say or I don't want to have any say in
like day-to-day operations at maker I
just want to focus on creating my
content and they're a great resource all
my merchandise has done throughout
arcade I have like contact people for
all the things I want to do we have a
cartoon I there's an animation
department or it's like I call them up
I'm like hey let's do this cartoon I
want to be a Viking and so then they
have writers and animators and they put
it all together and I show up and do the
voice-over and then they create the
videos and upload them and then you say
they but I mean it's the beauty of it is
is being a founder is that it's weaved
you know yeah it's my company you know
like I I'm like I want to do this but if
if those things do well then it's like
you know like like for instance
negotiating the contract for the split
between my channels and maker studios is
kind of this catch-22 because I'm
negotiating for my channel but maker
wants to get a bigger cut
that's kind of like me because I I'm a
maker yeah so it's like I get a cut of
the cut that makers taking so there's
weird things like that but it makers
exploded you know like there's 400
employees there no and those are 400
jobs that didn't exist four years ago
they weren't even in the marketplace
four years ago and so that's cool like
my grandma was just in town because we
had this new baby and my mom was in town
and I took her on maker studios and she
was just like wow you know and I'm even
that way when I walked through there I'm
like I don't know how fat these people
and how did that have a mean the start
of it it was kind of forged through
friendship with you yeah Danny and Lisa
it was out of necessity like we I flew
out to LA to help them with a brand deal
they had a brand deal with Fox I think
to promote crank to that movie with
Jason Statham we're here to keep his
heartbeat above a certain rate and Danny
called me and he said hey I got this
brand deal we need to get like five
different youtubers to make videos for
this deal we can pay you $2,000 and fly
you out to LA and we'll shoot help you
shoot an edit this video and I was like
yeah dude that would be great coming
from Idaho so I flew out to LA
Cillian if-if-if right and I would have
said yes to that brand deal with you
then we would should have hindsight's
2020 you guys could be rich - you came
into town and what you brought in a few
peopie came into town we made that video
and I was like this is so awesome they
brought in a few people oh yeah like
they're like hey we're gonna start this
company and so I phil was like on a road
trip I'm like dude you should move to LA
cuz he was living in Georgia Atlanta at
the time and he was on this big road
trip he was doing like meet and greets
all over the country he stopped in LA we
had moved to LA already so we hung out
and like dude were starting this company
you should join it they got shane dawson
Kassem G you know all these people it's
like let's join let's start this company
which promote each other's called the
station yeah that was the name of the
the channel was the station but maker
studios always existed as a company but
the you know the the channel that we're
all going to be part of was the station
and so yeah like I remember when we
started the station and start uploading
those first videos it would like
exploded like we all gained
thousand subscribers over like a week's
time because it was like everybody was
pushing in and then ever and then it
pushed out you know it's like everybody
push their audience into the station and
then in in Reverse like all that
audience pushed out and subscribed to
all the members of the station and
that's I mean that's kind of like so but
it was basically let's Danny had the Fox
deal and he was like let's form a
business around that well let's form a
partnership where we can keep doing this
together because we're powerful because
with our views exactly together so yeah
that was like the first you know I came
down we made that video and it was like
wow all these youtubers working together
cuz before that you there was collabs on
YouTube but it was like people would
email clips to each other right this is
yeah as far as my knowledge the first
time where a bunch of youtubers came
together and we're like in each other's
videos like Danny shot that video for me
and then Lisa edited it and I had no
editing knowledge like I was on move I
movie maker
you know like Windows Movie Maker and I
was horrible at editing and they had
Final Cut Pro and they had like a boom
Pole and I was like they're so Hollywood
they have this microphone on a stick you
know I was like holy crap before that
like my wife is holding this digital
camera and we had no idea what we were
doing so that up the quality of my
content because these were people that
had been making videos for longer than
me and so as we're they're making this
videos for Fox he's like I'm thinking
about a business where we all make these
videos together and we'll help each
other and like we'll come up with ideas
for each other and we'll act in each
other's videos and we'll help each other
edit and shoot and it's just like this
little community of youtubers creating
content and we'll just like kind of help
each other out I was like that sounds
great that sounds like a lot like that's
gonna help me and so that was you know
the idea after this video that we shot
and I moved home I went back to Idaho
after like being in LA for three days
and I told Colet I'm like let's move to
Los Angeles and she's like no you know
no way are we moving to LA because this
I had we had been doing the daily vlogs
for two months and started to get the
checks for the daily vlogs and that was
when I was like this is my full-time job
now that like two months after
doing the daily vlogs that my checks
jumped like huge it was like all of a
sudden I was making more doing YouTube
than I was doing my granite countertop
business and so it went from this this
YouTube thing is helping us pay our
bills to this is the biggest this is our
this is I'm making more money doing
YouTube than granite so I'm like I'm
done doing granite and I just dove into
YouTube with everything was like ever
I'd slept and breathed YouTube you know
any any YouTube gathering that was
happening I'd go to I read I've read
probably a hundred thousand comments you
know just like an alts wrote a book
Allen D Stroh wrote a book member allenl
estufa oh yeah he's a youtuber they
talked to him today
did you he did not yeah Jesse oh yeah
for dftba yeah he wrote a book I read
that book from cover to cover like you
know I've I've read like three YouTube
books you know just because I wanted to
know every in and out you know it was
just it was a dream come true of a dream
I never knew my even had made the
alliance's from the beginning of the
station AKA maker as a company who would
have known that it would have turned
into this oh you know you at the time
never in a million years I'd never a
dream that we would have four hundred
people working at maker studios but it
goes from let's help each other get
views and then let's work on brand deals
and sell against that - oh let's we can
sell against this entire audience for
even more brand is and the money just
starts coming in yeah I it's it's it's
just the nature of the internet you know
the Internet has exploded that much in
the last four years that it was just
great that we started at an Internet
company you know but I'm interested in
the dynamic of having to become a
businessman you stay you're not involved
in the day-to-day of maker yet you kind
of have to come out of the woodwork and
be the spokesman when things hit the fan
right imes you know I mean Danny's not
involved anymore there's I mean I don't
follow the ins and outs of these things
but you know with the whole
raywilliamjohnson kind of thing that was
like what what is happening then you
find yourself in a position where you
are the
spokesperson for maker studios right
which is never a position that I like
asked for but it I think it was just the
nature of that I made videos of my life
every day and a major part of those
videos was this little family that lived
in Idaho moving out to Los Angeles
California to start a business and so it
was very public you know it was like
something I talked to the audience with
him like hey guys you know this is when
we lived in Idaho I'm like we're gonna
move to California and start a business
with some of our youtube friends so we
were very transparent about that whole
process so it's like oh yeah Shay
Carly's going out so anytime somebody
wanted to check in on the station or
check in on maker studios I'm making a
video every day of being a part of that
process so I think just by default I
somehow become the face of maker studios
so the day that I hear that
raywilliamjohnson is tweeting all these
things and leaving maker studios because
of his contract I was never even there
when he signed his contract I had no
idea what his deal was or what the
negotiations were but the second that he
comes out and starts 20 min he's leaving
maker studios all these tweets come
pouring in hey what's going on with
raywilliamjohnson like I don't know I
have no idea I've met the guy like twice
in my whole life and ever he's like
thinking that I should like speak up and
say something I'm just like I have no
idea what his deal is what what the
contract is or any of that so it's like
you know I'm getting all these tweets
and it's to the point where I'm like
well I don't have to say anything about
it but then it's like so many tweets
it's like if I don't say something about
it then it seems like I'm hiding
something you know because it's like
well you're shaycarl you like you went
and started this company it's all in the
video so I'm like I guess I got to make
a video you know at that point I just I
you know I just try to stand up for my
friend and the company that I started
and you know I don't I don't I don't
have any hard feelings for Rey you know
they had an disagreement and Danny
diamond is not the easiest person to get
along with I think that's no that's no
secret
but that's one thing I love about Danny
Danny diamond is one of those people
that's like if you're his friend
he's like the best friend that you'll
ever have like you want him on your side
but if he's not your friend you hate him
you know it's like oh dad Danny diamond
guy but if you're friends it's like he's
the strongest friend you'll ever have
you know and he'll back you up any day
of the week but if you're not for
with him then you hate him you know it's
like ray I mean you said you met ray
twice yeah I literally have met ray
william johnson maybe i met him once at
in new york at the seven eight-nine
gathering where he just came up and we
had like he knew a guy that I was
friends with and so we talked about that
it's literally like shook hands and met
the only night that I've actually like
hung out and talked with Ray as one
night me and Kassim and Ray went to the
viper room and saw wax perform which is
like a this guy that's a rapper and then
afterwards we went to Ray's hotel room
and like hung out for like an hour and
just talked but other than that yeah
like I've met ray like I said three
times you know but I I think Ray's smart
man he's smart and he's you know he
knows what he's doing
I mean my questions aren't really
getting you to dish on anybody anyway
it's more of being everyone don't you
link no it's how you find yourself in a
place where like you said you have to
you have to speak up about these things
as well it's like I remember I was in
junior high I was friends with Sean T
Bronson and Jody Eames and Jody hated
Sean C and Sean C hated Jody these are
two sounds like girls names but these
are like real friends of mine and yeah
so if I hung out with Jody
Sean C was pissed like why are you
hanging out with him I'm like cuz I like
we get along and we play sports but Sean
C was like my skater friend who had long
hair and Jody hated Sean C because like
he's such a punk so it kind of punk
hairstyle and but I like skateboarding
and skiing so I liked hanging out with
both of these guys but I was like I was
always in the middle of like oh if I
hang out with Shanti I can't tell Jody
and so a lot of times with like YouTube
drama I feel like that's the position
I'm in cuz I feel like I'm friends with
everybody and I have no problems with
people because a lot of you know this
whole process a lot of people were young
you know and they're like kind of
figuring out who they were I was a 27
year old man with three kids you know
it's like I already knew who I was so
when all this like quote-unquote drama
happened I was just like oh you know
it's like I'm just kind of stuck in the
middle of it you know that's like I have
to kind of like play like you know play
nice everybody and you know then
sometimes I just get sucked into it
because you know just by association you
know where you were you did you find
yourself in the same position with it
when the whole Danny thing went down
that's a different I mean that's an
ongoing thing right now so know how much
I want to talk about that but I mean
yeah I mean I I still hear it yeah I
mean yeah I mean I probably shouldn't
talk much about that I mean we're still
friends and friendly but there's just
it's a tale is all this time man it's a
big company you know you know it's like
money and success and it splits people
up I'm still friends with all these
people but it's it's it's cost a couple
friendships and relationships just
because of the nature of Pride and
grieve and you know all those things so
and and it's not it's just like any
fight ever nobody's right my dad you
always say takes two people to fight you
know there's always two sides of the
story and you know usually each side is
a little bit right and it's just you
know people just disagree
my buddy Dave Ramsey says and like maybe
you guys might not agree with this
because you guys are a partnership he
has a saying that says the only ship
that sinks is a partnership do you guys
ever find yourself getting into fight
does rhettandlink ever fight about
business we've cut we're kind of beyond
partnership at this point I tell you
guys telling stories about third grade
like you guys are or first grade if you
want to go back then I was listened to
yeah like somebody punched you and it's
a form of marriage you suck up yeah yeah
well it's vice versa if I have to split
hairs he did stand up for me Jonathan
right John Carson were coming after you
yeah John Carson yeah so maybe it's more
of like you wouldn't take the partner
business partnership but you and Colette
there's a partnership there that's a
marriage partner for sure right now not
married but it's somewhere between the
two and here's the crazy thing about
Danny and maker studios is I would have
ran the business a lot different than
Danny did I would have grown maker
studios a lot slower I would have tried
to like lay out a good foundation if if
it wasn't for Danny makers who just
wouldn't be where it is today maker
studios is huge in this market now
because of the way the Danny built it
and it was just like explode like you
know it's a gold rush and he was right
you know
in this industry at this time it's like
it's happening so fast I would have done
it a lot slower
he was just like we need to get more
people we need to sign more channels
just like more advertising and all these
big plans and like whoa dude let's just
slow down and like just work on some
good YouTube videos but he like he had
this mind like we gotta get marketing we
have to have this department and he
would we'd always tease him because he
would just go off on these tangents
these rants and he would be like pulling
his hair I was like a mad scientist of
the internet you know it's like we're do
this and this I'm like whoa what do you
mean a sales team we have like 10 sales
people win like why and now we have that
so um Bish's he was a visionary you know
where I was going like he saw he saw
where it was going and you know you
gotta hand it to him like maker studios
is a huge player in our industry so he
because of today today the CEO is a nun
who is a former CEO of Endemol which is
a production company out of Europe and
he's running he's running things now and
he he's a great guy I really appreciate
him and he's done a lot of good things
from maker as well it's like Danny it
was like the you know the mad scientist
who had the idea and got it all going
and then all sudden we have 300
employees and it's a major company and
he's never been a CEO before so it's
like he doesn't know how to like run
these meetings and how to like get HR
together and like we're learning all
this stuff like there's insurance in
401ks and like all that kind of stuff
it's like we're just kids who are making
YouTube videos you know so it's like all
this money like Time Warner put all this
money in and it's like we don't know how
to do all this like it's like the thing
that outgrew us you know so it you know
when Danny left when he stepped down a
CEO that was actually a good night I
remember we had a big meeting went over
to his house and it was like we did it
like we got it to a point where this
majors were bringing in this major guy
who's a CEO of this giant company who's
now gonna run this company that we just
started off of a whim four years ago and
it was like good job we did it and then
you know other things have happened
since then but um yeah it's it's a it's
a success story if you ask me like who
are the other founders that are still in
that we know I know Lisa Ben Kassim Ron
hi I'm Ron and then Danny still owns
shares I might get in trouble for some
of this stuff I don't know what I'm
supposed to be
this really suits your lawyer here no
this is not being recorded dudes talking
about our life right yeah right I tell
you about this time that I made out with
my girlfriend and her mom this is just
perfect time for four hours now we can
wrap up but I mean family man we all
have not any children to get back home
to yeah I mean I will say you know to be
staggering success in four years and
watching it happen right from the
sidelines makes you better know it is
amazing to see what has happened at
maker and you know I think it's fabulous
it's cool I think it's you know a rising
tide raises all ships I think it's good
for anybody in the business you know
it's you know the more that we get you
know as far as like I hate saying you
know what people always like when people
start taking youtubers seriously or
what's the word uh come on you guys
where's your vocabulary here uh
legitimacy yeah yes thank you uh link I
love you it's like when you need to
sneeze when you can't think of a word
it's like driving you crazy and you say
that word that you're trying to think of
it's a good sneeze thank you
achoo uh yeah like I feel like you know
the more stories of Time Warner
investing 20 20 million dollars into
this industry it legitimizes all of us
and it shows you know mainstream
Hollywood that you know this is the new
form of entertainment and you guys are
great at creating that and you guys were
you know pioneers of that who have done
TV you guys have your own TV show or had
your own TV show and are still making
great content this is the future because
that's that's a question I always get
asked is like okay now that you're you
know you have this YouTube success when
you're gonna get your own TV show it's
like well I don't want a TV show I want
to be a pioneer of this brand new
exciting thing that is converging on
entertainment right now and be able to
talk about this ten years from now and
be like remember when you know well
you're certainly that I you know so back
to this whole when you hit the five-year
mark you said that you could if I told
you you know what Shay I can see the
future and at that five year mark
that's gonna be it you're gonna you're
gonna turn off the vlog faucet there's
not gonna be any more videos from you or
your family you could believe me I would
be okay with that scenario like I
wouldn't be sad about it but I just
don't see that realistically happening I
feel like our family will be on the
Internet in some capacity for a long
time I think if I'm realistic with
myself I think I'll always be on YouTube
I think I'll always be one as long as
it's there and as long as the audience
is there I think I'll always want to
create things and just have that outlet
you know I just I need a little break
I think having a coming at the tail end
of five years of uploading a video every
day I think after I get like a month of
just like fresh air and can like back
away from it
I think I'll come back refreshed and
more excited about it than ever you know
well that being said thank you for
spending two hours with us yeah yeah
this has been good it's fun I'll listen
I'll listen I hope I don't listen to
this later and be like I always say that
you guys are just so disarming so
handsome and I just want to talk to you
guys one thing that's the key and why
did you guys make me sit on the floor
alright grab that sharpie why don't you
sign up oh cool we're a roundtable of
dim lighting Harley took up a giant part
here look at all these people
you got Tyler Oakley Hannah Hart grace
where's Phil's signature I love your
faces were right there I'm gonna can I
write thanks for the shoutout
yeah yeah do that I'm gonna complete the
circle
and there it is the conclusion of our
epic conversation two-parter with
shaycarl yeah you know I found it very
interesting more than interesting sure
that he was he's at this point where he
could stop this like you know he
actually there's a part of him that
wants to stop there's an impulse to want
to get out I mean he said if he could
cash in on his his portion of maker
studios that if if that could happen
that he he might just walk away from the
whole the whole endeavor of being on the
Internet but then you know he backtracks
on that he starts to think about the
impact it would have on his audience and
the impact that it would have on him as
a creative person so I I mean he's he's
certainly still processing that I don't
think the headline will be Shea is
quitting but it could be Shea's cut Shea
thinks about it sometimes or a lot of
times well I would assume that those of
you who have tuned in to this two-part
series with shaycarl right here on ear
biscuits who are Shaytards fans this
might be you might be shaking in your
boots a little bit if you think oh the
five-year mark comes and these won't be
daily or whatever I'm sure you're gonna
want to let your voice be heard you know
there's ways to do that we're not we're
not encouraging you to go bombard the
Shaytards with comments of saying please
don't quit because I think this was this
was Shea just being honest I you know I
appreciate his honesty about everything
from his his belief system to the
decisions that he made to start the
family vlog why he continues it his
candidness about maker studios I mean
you know this guy has lived quite a life
and there's there's a lot there and he
was very he was he wasn't guarded about
any of it I really appreciate that
and I'm empathetic to you know the
impulse to want to quit when you do
something every day for four five years
yeah yeah you know I mean give the guy a
break I mean that's one of the reasons
we have seasons on good mythical morning
is because you know it's we like variety
and we like to him and we do a lot of
different things on the show and we and
we know people want it to come back but
we stop it
because we want to like it because when
we like it you like it you know I mean
when we're having a good time you have a
good time if you do anything long enough
it it gets old I mean I think about late
night television hosts like Kimmel
Fallon all those guys you know that
daily grind if I got to do this again
even though it's like a dream job it's
difficult my grandma nanny Lucille is a
late-night show host is a late-night
show host in Canada no she folded shirts
a t-shirt factory in Lillington North
Carolina for her entire working life Wow
just that job and it's a main folder
main shirt what in it I'm gonna have her
come over just fold shirts for you know
do you know how those dress shirts you
get will have like pins everywhere and
then there will be some of this is
inspected by number 279 she was a number
she was one of those numbers and she was
she would also put the pins in the shirt
and things like that the factory sits
closed but her and her younger sister
ain't Vicki who she lives with they both
work there their entire working lives
and she was always so happy yeah it's
just this mentality of well this is my
job I'm shirt folder this is what I do
and I come home and I fried the chicken
and I live my life
I think it's generational I mean yeah we
live in a time where everybody thinks
that they have to do something that they
love and you know and we encourage that
I mean we get to do something that we
love and we tell people to go do
something you love but I think the the
stark reality is that for most of the
world you have to do something that you
can do that will pay the bills yeah and
you know it's a privilege to do anything
that you even enjoy even just a little
bit is a privilege you know so it's not
a right it's definitely not it right
yeah so I'll say I'm empathetic too you
know Touche and him having him doing
this and being true to the commitment
but I don't think what you're saying is
that
family vlogging and shirt folding are
the same over time he can feel the same
I think it's what I'm what I'm saying
and what I'm saying is that he still
gets to do so as he acknowledged he gets
to do something that's absolutely
incredible that it's a job he isn't
folding shirts but you still might get
tired of it even if you love it you
might get tired of it yeah and you know
I mean that that brings me to say we're
thankful to have the opportunity to be
able to do this show to be able to reach
your ears in this way we counted a
privilege to be able to have these
conversations with Sheikh Karl and all
of these other fascinating personalities
from the internet to be able to
understand what makes them tick where
they come from that's what your biscuits
yes and this is probably a good time to
announce our new project an all new
podcasts are coming out with called
folding shirts with rhett and Link just
gonna be a lot of shuffling noises in
some mild conversation and the
occasional oh I just pricked myself with
a pen yeah Sony look for them he will be
part of it yeah she'll be here we're
gonna bring nany she recently recovered
from a choking incident she's okay now
and she's gonna be folding some shirts
with us it'll be awesome look for that
look for that on the horizon in the
meantime keep enjoying the ear biscuits
they're gonna keep coming down the
factory line every week
[Music]
[Music]